11h03 bonjour bienvenue la guerre en
Ukraine est-elle en train de basculer
des milliers de kilomètres carrés de
territoires ont été récupérés par les
Ukrainiens en moins d'une semaine elle
significatif ou seulement la logique
d'une guerre qui n'en a aucune avant que
les Russes à nouveau ne reprennent
d'autres villes bonjour Alexis ferchak
bonjour journaliste au Figaro
journaliste actu aux Figaro très au fait
de ce qui se passe en Ukraine on analyse
ces cartes comme on a l'habitude
aujourd'hui allez je la montre cette
nouvelle carte finalement celle que vous
avez pu voir ce matin dans dans le
Figaro vous pouvez retrouver sur sur le
site alors
compliqué moi d'abord tout ça on parle
de contre-offensive qu'est-ce qu'il
s'est passé où est-ce qu'on en est alors
en fait il y a eu deux contre-offensive
ukrainiennes la souris pour comme chez
vous pour montrer et en fait il faut
bien voir à l'esprit que les tous les
derniers life qu'on a fait finalement on
a parlé d'une carte c'est deux derniers
mois qui avaient à peine changé et donc
vous voyez la carte jusqu'à présent bah
tout était en rouge et je suis dans tous
ces cités en rouge et finalement ça
bougeait très peu parce que les
Ukrainiens étaient sur la défensive et
les Russes essayer d'avancer dans le
dans le don basse là dans l'Est mais une
avancé quasiment pas ou quelques
centaines de mètres chaque jour c'était
rien et donc les Ukrainiens là ont lancé
deux contre-fensives début septembre la
première dans la région de de Kerson on
va reparler donc à l'extrême ouais le
dispositif russe d'accord donc dans le
sud du pays absolument dans le sud du
pays et une deuxième et là on voit tout
de suite les résultats immédiatement
au nord on va dire nord-est globalement
dans la région de kerkiff et là on voit
tout de suite bleu c'est les territoires
que les Ukrainiens ont repris Horus et
alors on va commencer par faire un peu
de quelle donnée quelques heures de
grandeur
par rapport à la France pour que les
hommes de grandeur c'est c'est frappant
l'Ukraine c'est 600000 km² d'accord je
simplifie mais c'est ici 100000 la
France c'est 550 on va dire les Russes
contrôlent contrôlaient on va dire
jusqu'à présent 120000 km². d'accord en
Ukraine jusqu'à il y a jusqu'à il y a
quelques jours 120000 km
de l'ensemble du territoire grosso modo
c'était 20% sachant que sur ces 120000
km² en fait il y avait 40000 qu'ils
avaient pris en 2014 c'était à la fois
la Crimée
la péninsule de Crimée et la partie du
don basque avait été prise en 2014 je
voyais c'est les deux zones orange plus
clair d'accord et finalement depuis
depuis le 24 février les c'était avait
solidifié c'était emparé de 80000 km²
avec le corridor au sud de La Londe
Carson
jusqu'aux combats
et une partie au nord qui était à la
fois le reste de leblas de lougan donc
on va reparler puisque le donbassade de
région c'est denisk et lougans et donc
les Russes avaient réussi à prendre
l'intégralité de le blaze de Lougansk et
puis par ailleurs ils avaient pris tout
un tas tout un territoire une une bande
de terre
dans une partie de le blaze de karkiv
car qui veuillez c'est la grande c'est
la deuxième ville ukrainienne à minuit
et demi d'habitants alors ils avaient
pas de prix pas pris tout le blaze de
car kiff mais ils avaient pris cette
partie qui désormais est en bleu
puisqu'elle était reprise par les
Ukraine bref les Israéliens
et donc cette zone en bleu plus les les
les zones ce qu'on voit pas très bien
mais là il y a pas grand chose mais il y
a quelques années le problème c'est
qu'il y a toujours des zones grises ah
mais mais globalement les Ukrainiens
officiellement on dit 6000 km² en
réalité quand on regarde les cartes on
est plutôt à 10000 d'accord j'ai vu
c'est l'équivalent d'un d'un département
français là donc là c'est un gros
département français on dire 10000 km²
et surtout 10000 km². bah c'est plus de
10 % de ce que les Russes sont repris
ont pris depuis le 24 février alors j'ai
vu un autre chiffre
qui m'intéresse c'est que oui il y a
120000 km² de territoire
occupé par les Russes mais depuis le
mois de juin il n'avait pris que c'est
ça qui est très rapide c'est ça
absolument même quasiment pas 1700 je
crois 1700 1700 donc en une semaine les
les Ukrainiens ont récupéré 6000 km², on
va dire enfin c'est toujours difficile
on va dire 10000 et 2000 ils ont pris
les Ukrainiens ont pris en quelques
jours cinq fois plus que les Russes en
un mois voilà si on
et ça ça montre qu'est-ce que ça montre
ça montre qu'on était dans une guerre de
d'usure au final la la ligne de front
était arrêtée depuis deux trois mois
quasiment enfin il fallait vraiment
zoomer pour voir les différences et on
est repassé à une guerre de manœuvre
mais sauf que la à l'initiative bah ce
ne sont pas les Russes ce sont les
Ukrainiens voilà donc maintenant la
question c'est
qu'est-ce que ça représente cette
victoire
ukrainienne indubitable et éclatante et
où est-ce qu'on va aller dans les dans
les prochaines semaines voilà je salue
ceux qui nous rejoignent VLF 2022 de 13h
de retrouver ce live oui vous êtes
nombreux à nous suivre chaque semaine il
faudrait que Vincent roseron toujours
avec Alexis fairja qui qui analyse tout
ça Tommy également je vous salue vous
n'hésitez pas à vous réagissez et on en
parle Tommy qui nous dit beaucoup de
bruit pour pas grand chose c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser peut-être
est-ce que oui on récupère des
territoires mais c'était mon mon
introduction est-ce que à terme dans les
semaines qui viennent à nouveau les
Russes repr une partie de territoire et
ça peut se passer comme ça pendant des
années
des années on n'est pas prophètes donc
on va pas faire de prévision sur des
années ce qu'on peut dire actuellement
la réalité est toujours nuancée donc on
peut pas parler de complète des routes
de l'armée russe pour une raison simple
c'est qu'ils ont réussi l'ambassadeur
français à Kiev le redisait encore ce
matin sur France Info les Russes ont à
peu près réussi à se replier en bon
ordre ça veut pas dire ça veut pas dire
qu'ils ont
ils ont laissé sur place énormément de
matériel
en bonne ordre c'est à dire que il y a
quand même probablement
dans cette région il devait y avoir
20000 ou 30 000 soldats russes
globalement ils ont réussi
à se replier mais évidemment en laissant
énormément de de
matériel de munitions d'équipements et
puis il y a eu ces indubitable aussi des
prisonniers on ne sait pas encore
combien
visiblement
il y en a eu beaucoup mais il y en a pas
eu suffisamment pour qu'on puisse parler
d'une déroute complète il y a eu un
reply russe qui qui s'est passé dans des
dans des conditions évidemment précaires
mais il y a eu un replius j'ai une
question Alexis qu'on me pose là sur sur
Youtube on va parler dans un instant de
cette partie nord-est du pays qui nous
intéresse plus précisément pour savoir
ce qui s'est passé hein le broking
est-ce que les territoires de l'Est sont
si stratégiques pour les Russes
l'important c'est ce que ce n'est pas le
sud pour faire la liaison avec la Crimée
alors et je remontre la carte précédente
parce que c'est intéressant
c'est là où il faut être là encore
nuancé pour les Russes le plus
stratégique c'est effectivement le sud
de l'Ukraine ici ici absolument et
notamment c'est cette notion de corridor
terrestre qui relie la Crimée et le
donbasse parce qu'en fait la Crimée
n'est reliée au territoire russe que
auparavant elle n'était relié que par ce
pont que les Russes ont construits entre
2014 et 2022 ici et qui est le pont du
détroit de cash je vois pas très bien
le détroit de kercht et donc c'est
extrêmement limité et donc et donc il y
a cette continuité de prendre des
territoires absolument si pour faire la
liaison et donc c'est ce que là on le
voit il y a une continuité territoriale
dans tout le reste de l'Ukraine donc il
a pas forcément tort Reynard là quand il
nous dit bon peut-être qu'ils ont perdu
des fleurs dans le dos mais c'est pas
pour autant tu sais pas pour autant que
les régions de car kiffent
n'est pas stratégique alors pourquoi
parce qu'en fait le
il y a tout un enjeu de logistique et
qu'on voit bien sur la carte c'est que
le si vous voulez le don basse le car
kiff ça c'est un ici ça entoure le le
nom basse c'est que c'est entouré ici là
le on va dire le 2e je prends la souris
voilà encore une fois l'objectif
officiel numéro un des Russes c'est de
reprendre l'intégralité du don basse
qu'on voit là il y a l'ougance qui est
ici qui a été entièrement repris et puis
en dessous il y a deux nièce et donc les
territoires que les Russes avaient
repris
avait pris dans le dans la région de
kerkiff pourquoi c'était important
stratégiquement bah ça fait une sorte de
profondeur stratégique pour protéger le
Blas de lougance et par ailleurs vous
voyez il y a cette ville très importante
easy Youm ou encore cette ville Slimane
et bien donnez-moi la souris avec qui
j'ai perdu la carte un peu plus précise
où on zoome un peu comme ça on va
pouvoir un peu prendre voilà je vous
mets on est vous voyez cette petite
carte de l'Ukraine en
et vous voyez que cette région de kerki
valait été stratégique pour les flux
logistiques et notamment cette ville
grâce à cette partie qui a été récupérée
absolument par les ukrainiens et là on
voit même que cette ligne de chemin de
fer bah c'est très compliqué pas
forcément exploitable celle-là voilà et
donc c'est à dire c'est toute la
logistique russe maintenant qui est
entravé ou en TACA affaibli alors même
que c'était déjà c'est un point faible
historique déjà l'armée soviétique là
donc pour les Russes c'est c'est une
gageure on va voir s'il en est alors
maintenant on voit que quand même la
ligne de front c'est de nouveau à peu
près stabilisé alors il y a un fleuve
c'est ça il y a une rivière une rivière
le skill en fait
on va voir maintenant cette guerre en
Ukraine c'est il y a des fleuves et des
rivières partout qui délimitent la là
c'est le skill vous descendez le skill
et ensuite vous elle se jette dans une
autre rivière qui s'appelle le donutsk
d'accord qui donne son nom d'ailleurs à
la région
et là hop c'est de nouveau le donutsk
donc vous voyez c'est vraiment les
territoires russes maintenant suivent
c'est très bien le problème c'est que
c'est pas une très grande rivière quel
est le nom de la première rivière au
skin edenet
et c'est pas une énorme rivière et donc
par endroits surtout qu'on est encore en
été malgré tout pas on doit on peut la
traverser sans trop de difficultés là
vous voyez ça c'est dans cette dynamique
actuelle avec les Ukrainiens qui
reprennent les territoires c'est plutôt
favorable c'est plutôt favorable et donc
il y a aussi un enjeu de temps de
calendrier les Russes s'ils sont dans
une logique défensive et on va voir qui
qui vont le réciter probablement dans
les dans les prochaines semaines voir
les prochains mois ils ont intérêt à
tenir parce que avec l'arrivée de
l'hiver bah cette série a le niveau de
l'eau va monter et ça sera plus dur pour
les Ukrainiens de la franchise alors
sachant que vous voyez il y a un petit
territoire bleu en bas
si vous voulez la contre-offensive
ukrainienne elle elle a poussé dans
l'Est là dans l'Ouest là où il y a tous
les grands territoires bleues mais aussi
un peu dans le département du service
international qui était avec moi il me
disait cette zone elle est encore un peu
floue elle est complètement dans la zone
grise et pour une raison simple c'est
que autant les Russes fassent au
Ukrainiens c'était pas un choix mais
face aux Ukrainiens ils ont quand même
décidé de se replier
ils se sont repliés notamment de la
ville d'izum qui est qui est au-dessus
du Grand voilà absolument
ils se sont retirésia de de de coup de
pions c'est maintenant ils sont à la
limite avec confiance en revanche au sud
avec la ville de Liman là il résiste ils
savent très bien que parce que il y a la
rivière de NES qui passe juste en
dessous si les Ukrainiens arrivent à
faire une tête de pont sur le deniek et
à remonter vers le nord c'est tout le
dispositif russe qui s'écroule et en
plus d'un symbole politique c'est-à-dire
que les Russes ne pourraient plus dire
on contrôle l'intégralité le Blas de
lougans donc à cet endroit là ils
tiennent et le redéploiement il va
probablement se faire là les les Russes
ont tout intérêt à tenir cette zone là
de même qu'en dessous c'est vers
donetsky chance deux questions une qui
viendra de moi une d'abord du chat sur
Youtube Minos qui nous dit attends une
idée de perdre du Maine dans cette
opération la des derniers jours est-ce
qu'on sait ça on n'a pas de de on n'a
pas de chiffres ici donc j'ai pas en
donner ça sert à rien les rues sont dit
qu'ils avaient tué 2000 Ukrainiens mais
franchement que c'est parce que ça veut
les les
Ukrainiens n'ont pas donné de chiffres
et
ce qu'on sait c'est que les les il y
avait énormément de mouvements vers les
vers les hôpitaux de la région mais
c'est mais c'est c'est logique si vous
voulez c'était faut bien avoir en tête
que les Ukrainiens se sont lancés dans
deux offensives d'ampleur une dans le
sud et celle-ci dans avec probablement
20 à 30 000 hommes pour chaque mener en
même temps à deux endroits différents de
la carte dans un grand pays deux
offensives combinés de 20 à 30000 hommes
c'est une gageure que peu d'armée dans
le monde sont capables de mener l'autre
question que je voulais vous poser vous
avez déjà abordé un peu ça au début de
ce soleil le repli Russ on se souvient
ils étaient assez proches de Kiev au
printemps ils se sont repliés c'était
déjà
avec là on a pas assez c'était assumé
mais encore une fois c'était assumé
étant donné par ailleurs que leur plan
initial n'avait pas fonctionné bien sûr
bien sûr il faut possible vous avez
raison mais est-ce que on est dans la
même situation ici ou non là on est
clairement sur des défaites et c'est la
débandade et on recule et on laisse des
armes et ça se passe beaucoup moins bien
parce qu'on n'a pas décidé de reculer
alors on apparence il y a ce repli on
peut dire que ça ressemble mais il y a
des grandes différences c'est que
après le repli de Ken donc je rappelle
qu'il y avait eu à la fin du toute fin
du mois de mars ces derniers jours du
mois de mars tout début avril après cela
Poutine avait redisposé ses hommes dans
le non-basse ce qui redit d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui mais la différence c'est que
il avait maintenu l'initiative c'est
dire qu'il avait redéployé ses hommes
donc il était replié puis il avait gardé
conserver l'initiative en attaquant le
bon masque là c'est la différence c'est
très différent puisque là ce sont les
Ukrainiens qui sont toujours à
l'initiative là les rues sont perdus
l'initiative de de depuis quelques
semaines et c'est peut-être là où on
peut parler d'un tournant de la guerre
c'est la première différence et par
ailleurs la deuxième différence c'est
que si vous voulez le front du Nord
autour de Kiev il était absolument
distinct du front de l'Est le fait
d'avoir perdu
à l'ouest de Kiev et au nord de Kiev
n'avait pas d'impact direct sur le
non-basse alors là ce que je vous ai
expliqué c'est que les territoires au
nord à carquis au nord du Dombas ou un
impact militaire direct sur le Donbass
puisque c'était c'est
[Musique]
c'était à Carson peut-être que elle est
très importante mais peut-être que
c'était aussi une manière de fixer des
troupes bruses et de cacher
la grande offensive à Cardiff mais celle
de Carson est quand même très important
la différence c'est qu'elle a été lancée
quelques jours avant celle du quartier
et que en revanche pour le coup les
Russes ont résisté ils se sont pas
repliés en tout cas pour l'instant alors
vous me confirmez c'est la première
ville première grande ville prise par
les Russes au tout début absolument
c'est la seule capitale régionale 400000
habitants
aujourd'hui mais à l'origine c'était 400
mille habitants ce qui est important de
voir c'est que donc Carson est à
l'embouchure d'une Nièvre le niAme c'est
le grand fleuve qui traverse l'Ukraine
du nord au sud et en fait toute cette
partie tous ces territoires contre les
par les Russes sont à l'ouest du Nièvre
et en fait il y a que deux ponts pour
passer de ce territoire ici
en toutnowski et l'autre j'ai oublié son
deux ponts on le voit en bleu là voilà
et c'est pour ont été détruits par les
Ukrainiens juste avant qu'ils ont lancé
leur offensive et donc là les Russes ont
un énorme problème de logistique là
encore une fois comment font-ils
comprendre pour ravitailler en homme
pour changer on peut pas la gueule pour
envoyer de nouvelles unités pour les
Russes c'est un cauchemar stratégique
parler de presqu'île désormais de
personnes ça donne une bonne image du
fait que cette zone là elle est très
difficile à défendre pour les Russes et
donc pour l'instant ils tiennent
j'accélère peut-être un peu mais ils ne
peuvent même pas se replier là et si les
oreilles de mal à se replier sauf à
passer à la nage non on voit il y a des
pontons mais mais si vous voulez il y a
probablement 20000
soldats russes un dans deux grandeurs
si jamais il y a une décision de repli
c'est très compliqué voilà alors pas les
alimenter et ils ne peuvent pas se
replier ou en tout cas tout ça est
difficilement voilà très difficile donc
si vous voulez les Russes sont là à cet
endroit là on fait le choix de ne pas se
replier de tenir mais malgré tous les
Ukrainiens grignotent du territoire
alors là encore une de nouveau une
rivière vous voyez la ligne de front là
et définie par une rivière qui s'appelle
linkullet d'accord et donc les
Ukrainiens mais depuis pas mal de
semaines maintenant on réussit à faire
une petite tête de pont qu'on voit là
juste là et donc ils ont franchi la
rivière et donc il grignote grignote les
fortifications russes et combien de
temps les Russes vont-ils pouvoir tenir
bien c'est pas donc ça c'est un premier
enjeu dans le sud et donc là les Russes
ils perdaient cet endroit là non
seulement ils perdrait Carson ou en tout
cas la partie à l'Est enfin sur la rive
à l'ouest de Carson qui a la principale
donc il n'aurait plus accès à l'autre
partie du Nièvre et surtout c'est le
niep qui ravitaille en la Crimée ce qui
était une des raisons principales voilà
depuis 2014
rapidement voilà donc ça c'est un jeu
maintenant il y a un autre enjeu dont on
commence à parler sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment russe donc ça faut
voir mais il y aurait pas mal de troupes
ukrainiennes dans le sud de l'Ukraine
pour le coup plus à l'Est d'accord on va
dire au-dessus de Mario Paul dans la
dans cette taux de région qui s'appelle
les aporidia d'accord
les Russes qu'on trouve une grande
partie de la région de zapparaisja y
compris la centrale nucléaire des
nerudouard mais mais pas la la ville
principale de ce qui est beaucoup plus
honneur et donc là s'il y avait c'est
l'une des questions est-ce que les
Ukrainiens maintenant vont stabiliser
cette ligne digérer leur conquête
est-ce que ils vont recommencer leur
offensive
et donc quelle direction est-ce que ça
va être on en a parlé tout à l'heure à
Liman pour détruire le dispositif russe
par le nord est-ce que ça va être dans
le sud à par exemple pour foncer à Mario
Paul et couper en deux les territoires
est-ce que ça va être de continuer à
faire pression sur Carson à l'ouest
franchement j'ai pas la réponse mais on
verra dans les dans les prochains jours
Christian Léon Toussaint toujours
présent sur le Figaro.fr Lulu qui nous
dit l'Ukraine doit tout faire pour que
Poutine ne prenne pas au dessin oui ça
c'est complètement oublié on peut le
dire
ça fait je pense que ça fait 10 ça fait
10 lives que qu'on répète que
on précise oui j'ai plein de
commentaires qui nous disent Godard est
mort oui oui évidemment c'est une autre
actualité on y reviendra tout à l'heure
vers midi et quart sur sur cette
actualité et le décès du réalisateur
suisse j'ai j'ai plein de questions
Florian Richard qui qui me dit les
Russes n'ont-ils pas fait une grave
erreur en concentrant leur force au sud
déjà est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce qu'ils
ont concentré leurs efforts au sud je me
souviens quand ils avaient quitté Kiev
les alentours de Kiev ils Vladimir
Poutine disait l'objectif c'est le
bombasse nous mettons nos forces dans le
basse oui alors ce qu'il y a c'est que
c'est ce que je vous dis tout à l'heure
il y a eu des ils ont été obligé de
d'enlever des troupes
dans le Nord pour les envoyer vers
Carson et dans le sud de l'Ukraine plus
généralement parce qu'ils avaient peur
de cette grande offensive d'été
ukrainienne dans dans le sud mais ça il
y a un problème beaucoup plus général
c'est que les Russes ont attaqué avec
150 à 250 000 hommes un pays grand plus
grand que la France voilà
ça nous paraît énorme 200000 hommes
c'est pas assez c'est absolument rien je
je n'ai pas le chiffre d'allemand qui
ont débarqué en France en mai 40 mais je
peux c’était largement plus d'un million
j'essaie de vous le trouver pour le
prochain live non 150000 à 200 000 sol
ça n'est absolument rien et notamment il
y a un énorme manque d'infanterie parce
qu'ils n'ont pas voulu envoyer les
conseils donc ils envoyaient que l'armée
professionnel et donc ils ont un manque
d'homme
engagés
même s'il n'était pas militaire
professionnel les les les Russes on l'a
vu notamment dans le non-basse sont sur
la défensif enfin même quand il était
qui ils étaient sur les défensifs qui
ils noyaient tous les territoires sous
l'artillerie mais ensuite ils
n'envoyaient pas l'infanterie pour
contrôler et saisir ces territoires
d'où le fait que les Russes ont atteint
une forme de point culminant c'est
qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens d'avoir
l'initiative on avance est-ce que c'est
un tournant dans cette guerre et tout
simplement est-ce que désormais les
Ukrainiens peuvent gagner et gagner on
peut définir ce que ça veut dire
récupérer les territoires avant le 24
février c'est ça où les territoires
avant 2014 on peut expliquer tout ça
parce que la victoire dans une guerre
politique
ultime des
Ukrainiens et objectifs officiel c'est
de tout reprendre donc les frontières de
l'Ukraine de 91 donc c'est à dire Crimée
compris pour l'instant on peut remontrer
sur cette carte pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent depuis le début de la guerre
le 24 février les Russes ont pris ces
zones en orange foncé ici ils avaient
cette zone qui est désormais en bleu qui
a été récupéré par les ukrainiens et
depuis 2014 ils étaient aussi ils
avaient pris possession par différents
moyens parce qu'il y avait des
séparatistes c'était pas forcément la
réussite en elle-même officiellement
c'était un direct voilà et donc avec
cette partie du don-basse en orange
clair et cette partie là Crimée en pas
cette partie d'ailleurs toute la Crimée
orange
eux ils veulent tout donc les frontières
de 91 donc l'intégralité de ces
territoires qu'on voit ici pour
l'instant la reprise de la Crimée
n'est pas d'actualité
en revanche à court terme ce qui se pose
c'est les territoires conquis par la
Russie depuis le 24 février d'accord
c'est à dire l'orange français l'orange
foncé c'est à dire le fait que la Russie
ait réussi à constituer un territoire
d'un seul tenant de la Crimée jusque
dans masse ensuite peut-être un moins
court terme mais
malgré tout le risque est là pour les
Russes c'est y compris de perdre le
Dombas qu'il contrôlait depuis 2014 une
partie dont on va se battre
on n'en sait rien mais si vraiment il y
a un effondrement mais il ne contrôlait
pas tout le temps
la partie en orange clair donc le risque
il est là donc on va dire que les les
gains potentiels pour les Ukrainiens
c'est c'est d'abord le sud de l'Ukraine
déjà rien que d'entendre
je me rappelle je suis beaucoup moins
expert que vous mais le 24 février on
nous disait presque dans une semaine
c'est terminé l'Ukraine et Thomas de la
Russie non mais c'est pour ça que la
prudence est toujours de de
de mise quand on parle de de conflit ce
qui est clair c'est que qu'est-ce qui a
favori ça en 1 il y a la volonté de
combattre des
Ukrainiens le patriotisme qu'on a un
pays attaqué on se défend et là on en a
une illustration absolument manifeste 2
il y a évidemment les équipements
occidentaux qui ont été fournis depuis
énormément de depuis sa dernière dernier
mois et il y a une autre chose qu'on
voit mal mais qui est absolument
prépondérante et décisive c'est l'aide
en termes de renseignements
je reviens me disait hier c'est les
produits sont très mal renseignés par
rapport aux Ukrainiens ce qui peut
paraître étonnant mais en même temps les
ukanias sont renseignés directement par
les Américains donc ils profitent de de
moyens de renseignements qui sont enfin
excellentissime probablement les
meilleurs au monde et ça quand vous avez
une il y avait le général Kempf qui sur
Twitter si vous voulez c'est plein de
données de satellitaire mais ensuite ou
enfin de qui viennent de toutes les
sources mais ensuite c'est surtout le
traitement des données qui permet que
qui permet aux Ukrainiens d'avoir en
temps réel une estimation du dispositif
russe de manière extrêmement locale
extrêmement rapide et donc c'est comme
ça qu'ensuite quand on a les forces de
l'adversaire et ben on peut monter
planifier des contre-offensives et puis
il y a l'entraînement
l'entraînement des soldats Ukrainiens
qui se fait en réalité un peu depuis
2014 mais mais énormément monté en
puissance
depuis le 24 février les Anglais les
Américains et les mêmes un peu les
Français
et donc du coup on a vu au sol des
Ukrainiens qui se battaient très bien
comme des soldats modernes sur un champ
de bataille moderne alors que les Russes
on le voit malgré la fameuse grande
réforme brusque de 2008 en réalité on
voit encore
[Musique]
défensif pour quelques semaines voire
quelques mois il faut qu'ils arrivent à
reconstituer
des fortifications le long des rivières
dont je vous ai parlé le skill de nietzk
qu'ils arrivent à tenir le Sud alors
peut-être qu'une partie justement des
troupes qui se sont repliées dans le
carquis vont aller dans le sud par
ailleurs on parlait depuis des semaines
du troisième corps d'armée qu'un corps
d'armée qui a été créé par les Russes
ces dernières mois avec avec des
volontaires des volontaires entre
guillemets parce que
c'est jamais on n'a pas les informations
précises donc dans toutes les régions
russes
on peut être payé très cher pour partir
ce matin donc il y a ce troisième corde
armée on sait pas trop son volume c'est
ses qualités etc pour l'instant c'est
comme une menace pour les Russes l'enjeu
c'est c'est de tenir les territoires
qu'il contrôle la principale difficulté
probablement ça sera Carson qu'est-ce
que vont faire les Russes à car est-ce
que ils essayent de tenir mais là et ça
va être une guerre d'usure qui va être
très violente pour les Russes à cause
des soucis logistiques dont je voulais
parler ou est-ce qu'il essaie de se
replier ils abandonnent Carson ça serait
une défaite politique vraiment
importante pour et majeurs pour Poutine
maintenant on a remarqué une chose c'est
les bombardements contre des centrales
électriques
dans une bonne partie de l'Ukraine
d'accord et notamment dans l'est de
l'Ukraine qui a entraîné des coupures
d'électricité ça ça n'est pas il y a une
part il y a une part de vengeance
étonnamment depuis le 24 février les
Russes n'ont pas trop touchés
peuvent nous servir ensuite
je comprends alors ça faisait très
longtemps que les nationalistes russes
donc on va dire que ceux qui sont à la
droite de Poutine
demandez justement à ce que la Russie
bombarde toutes les infrastructures
civiles notamment capitale énergétique
bombarde les ponts sur le Nièvre
d'accord bombarde les centres
commandement russe
ukrainien par exemple à Kiev etc et pour
l'instant les les Russes ne l'avaient
pas trop fait là ce qu'on a vu donc
c'est la réaction immédiate c'était des
centrales électriques qui ont été
touchées notamment dans la région de
quartier il faut savoir que de bombarder
des objectifs civils c'est un crime de
guerre on n'a pas le droit d'accord mais
un objectif civil si il a un intérêt
militaire immédiat et prouvé peut être
défini comme un objectif unitaire
j'entends donc le centrale électrique
peut être un peu servir à des objectifs
militaires donc c'est le modèle
mais pourquoi les Russes pourraient
faire ça d'un point de vue militaire
c'est pour casser la logistique
ukrainienne pourquoi parce que ce qu'on
a dit pour les Russes le fait que la
logistique passe par le train il en va
de même
pour les yeux évidemment
et donc si vous voulez les Ukrainiens
qu'ont deux grandes contre-offensives
au point les plus éloignés ici
ils ont absolument besoin du train or ce
sont des trains qui fonctionnent à
l'électricité et donc s'il y a plus
d'électricité cette capacité de
mouvement et ses capacités logistiques
qui clairement favorisent actuellement
l'Ukraine et bah pour être extrêmement
entravé donc je pense que ça va être un
des
il faut s'attendre probablement à
d'autres attaques sur les sur les les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainiennes voir sur les ponts sur le
Nieppe on verra mais c'est probablement
des moyens de la Russie d'essayer de
contenir cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne je lis Machiavel le fameux
3e corps d'armée dont on parliez à
l'instant Alexis avec l'offensif staimar
on l'attend toujours c'est un peu ce que
vous me disiez énormément de rumeurs au
début ça devait être à Carson ensuite à
zapourrit déjà ensuite dans le don basse
etc pour l'instant encore une fois cette
capacité d'initiative russe c'est-à-dire
d'aller de l'avant et de lancer des
offensives
pour l'instant
c'est peu probable j'ai une question
encore et on achèvera ce live là-dessus
réaction russe on le sait la lumière
Poutine a brandi la menace nucléaire
est-ce que à nouveau alors ça fait
quelques temps qu'on entend plus
vraiment parler est-ce qu'il y a nouveau
la dernière Poutine et les gens qui
l'entourent pourraient brandir cette
menace notamment à cause d'attaque sur
la Crimée parce que la Crimée il tient
tout particulièrement
les Russes plusieurs fois on dit que
pour l'instant il n'avait pas besoin à
chaque fois qu'on les interrogé sur la
doctrine militaire russe nucléaire russe
ils ont toujours dit qu'ils avaient pas
besoin pour l'instant d'utiliser l'arme
nucléaire donc il y a eu des tentatives
d'escalade on va dire dans les discours
mais en même temps toujours c'était
redescendu
disons les choses clairement le
on peut jamais il y a pas de risque zéro
mais il y a peu de risques sauf la
question c'est les Crimée puisque la
Crimée officiellement du point de vue du
droit russe pas du point de vue du droit
international du droit russe c'est la
Russie
donc là c'est un enjeu
et ça pourrait devenir un ange mais
au-delà de ça ça pose la question de
l'escalade
est-ce que Poutine a les moyens
d'escalader c'est pour réagir à cette
contre-offensive
ukrainienne quelles sont ses moyens pour
escalader il y a toute une une gradation
avant l'escale nucléaire or Poutine là à
peu de moyens d'escalader sans
déclencher une véritable guerre puisque
officiellement c'est une opération
militaire spéciale
et qui dit guerre dit mobilisation et
notamment mobilisation des conscrits des
réservistes etc mais est-ce que
politiquement on interne Poutine peut se
le permettre pour l'instant il a
toujours dit plutôt de miettes
c'est la grande question de des semaines
et des mois à venir allez Alexis pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent parce qu'ils
sont nombreux on va acheter ce live mais
j'aurais qu'on refasse un point je vous
laisse trois minutes pour 3 minutes pour
expliquer de cette contre-offensive j'ai
deux cartes on commence par celle-ci
allons-y 2 contre-offensive ukrainienne
une heure dans la région de kerki où ils
ont repris de grands territoires une au
sud dans celle de de Carson où ils ont
pris moins de territoires mais les
Russes sont entre guillemets coincés sur
une presqu'île à cause d'une Nièvre et
où les Ukrainiens malgré tout grignotent
des territoires les
Ukrainiens ont repris environ 10000 km²
sachant que les Russes depuis le 24
février avaient pris 80000 km² en
Ukraine sur un total de 120 000 km²
depuis
pour l'instant la ligne de front c'est à
peu près stabilisée autour des rivières
au ski et de nièces là nous sommes dans
la question et j'ai pas de réponse c'est
est-ce que les Ukrainiens vont réussir à
relancer l'offensive vers Limane au sud
ici voilà et ou ailleurs d'ailleurs mais
à cet endroit là particulièrement ça
pourrait mettre en péril le dispositif
russe et notamment les Ukrainiens
pourraient rentrer dans le blast de
l'ougance qui contrôlait actuellement
entièrement par les par les
quasiment les jours qui ont suivi
l'offre la première offensive du 24
février non le grand
ça avait pris du temps c'est donc les
1er juillet la prise complète de voilà
et puis par ailleurs le grand enjeu j'ai
pas mangé c'est qu'est-ce qui va se
passer maintenant au sud de l'Ukraine
dans la région de la corridja voilà
est-ce que les
Ukrainiens vont continuer leur
contre-offensive d'ampleur pour
l'instant ils ont été capables de mener
deux front deux offensives avec 20 à 30
minimum qu'en est-il maintenant est-ce
que les est-ce que les Russes vont
réussir à contenir est-ce que ils vont
réussir à empêcher la logistique
ukrainienne de se déployer dans toutes
ces régions voilà c'est une question qui
se posent aujourd'hui et on fera
d'autres live évidemment c'est difficile
il est difficile d'établir un chiffre
mais entre 6000 et 10000 km² repris
c'est ça par les réalités l'équivalent
d'un département français ça donne un
ordre d'idée ça change sachant que les
les russes depuis le début de l'été
n'avait pris que 70000 km sur le
territoire ukrainien voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire donc de ses avancées de
cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans cette guerre qui qui se
poursuit merci beaucoup Alexis fairchack
merci beaucoup vous revenez alors si
vous avez raté le début pas de souci
c'est sur Youtube donc dans à peu près
deux minutes dès que je clôture ce live
vous avez à nouveau l'intégralité de
cette ce live spécial sur les cartes et
derrière en Ukraine oui merci à
l'infographie qui nous fournit chaque
jour chaque jour c'est carte vous restez
avec nous parce que dans un instant nous
parlerons et certains nous l'ont
réclamés dans le chat de Jean-Luc Godard
le réalisateur suisse s'est éteint et
nous ferons nous lui rendrons hommage
évidemment nous parlerons de ces films
avec Olivier Delcroix qui va me
rejoindre et puis toute la journée
l'actualité autour de ce qu'il se passe
au Royaume-Uni avec le prince Charles
qui est aujourd'hui au Pays de Galles et
puis ce soir évidemment la question du
jour point de vue le club politique tout
ça sur le figer là il vous reste avec
nous excellente journée merci de nous
avoir suivi